welcome back everyone this is the fifth
and final screencast in our unit on
information retrieval I thought I would
just point you to some data set
resources and then wrap up in what I
hope is an inspiring way
for data sets let's start with t-rec
this is text retrieval conference they
have annual competitions the 2023
iteration has a number of different
tracks that you might explore if you
want to get involved in these Bake Off
style competitions in general t-rec has
tended to emphasize careful evaluation
with small numbers of queries say 50
queries each with about 100 annotated
documents but that doesn't mean that you
have few documents it just means that
you're doing this kind of refined
evaluation
Ms Marco is an incredibly important
resource in the IR space it's the
largest public IR Benchmark it was
adapted from a question answering data
set and has more than 500 000 Bing
search queries as its basis
the labeling is pretty sparse one
relevance label per query but that does
match the setting that we need for
training all of the neural IR models
that I covered in the previous
screencast so this really is a wonderful
resource for passage ranking you have 9
million short passages and for document
ranking you have three million long
documents so that's two ways in which
you can explore system performance and
also create pre-trained resources that
will be useful to others who are looking
for IR Solutions
beer is an important new Benchmark that
stands for benchmarking ir and the name
of the game here is to do diverse zero
shot evaluations of ir models across a
bunch of different domains and task
settings and so this has been useful for
benchmarking these models recently we
released a kind of companion data set
that we call latte for long tail topic
stratified evaluation and the idea here
is to rely primarily on stack exchange
to explore pretty complicated pretty
diverse questions this is again meant
for zero shot evaluation and what we did
is release the data set with topic
aligned pairs of Devon tests so you can
do some development work testing your
system zero shot in the devs tests and
then try to transfer into kind of
comparable domains and another aspect of
latte is that we have a subpart that's
kind of oriented around the things that
you see in web search and a second
subpart Forum queries that are more
oriented to the kind of complicated
question that people pose directly in
forums like stack Exchange
xor tie-dye is a wonderful effort to
push IR into a more multilingual setting
both for QA and open QA and for Pure IR
applications certainly worth looking at
if you're thinking of developing
multilingual IR Solutions
and that's it for data sets there are
others but those are some Greatest Hits
and then I thought I would just list out
a few core topics that I really didn't
get to discuss first there is a large
literature on different techniques for
negative sampling remember all those
triples I described have a set of
negatives the question is where do those
come from and you always want to strike
a balance between making them really
easy so the model can discriminate and
making them hard so that the model
learns some subtle distinctions and
getting that balance right can be very
challenging
I also didn't get to talk enough about
weak supervision I did mention one
strategy where we kind of look to see
whether documents contain the query as a
substring and use that as a signal for
relevance and we have found in Prior
work that that simple heuristic can be
incredibly powerful and I think that
does suggest that especially for
training systems we should push toward
weak supervision for them because it can
be so effective and is often so
inexpensive
and then I've alluded to this a few
times in a recent paper we use Dyna
scores which is a method for integrating
a lot of different metrics together into
a single unified metric to create
leaderboards that kind of really embrace
all the aspects of ir and we're going to
talk about Dyna scores later in the
quarter and I think I'll return to the
IR example because it is such a good
example of how multiple pressures can be
in play when we think about system
quality
so that's it for data sets and then to
conclude I really wanted to just say one
final thing nlu and IR are back together
again in full force and this has
profound implications for research and
Technology development and I hope this
series of screencasts has showed you how
active and exciting this area of
research is and kind of push you to
think about how you could participate in
this research because you can have a
very large impact both within research
and also throughout the industry as it
tries to make use of language technology
so tremendously exciting scientifically
and technologically a wonderful and
inspiring story of how these fields have
come back together to achieve new and
bigger things